[Music]
i am a poet my words upon your lips
i will make you romantic will you make
me handsome
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
speak to me like you do in your letters
you are a beautiful flower i am not a
flower i need more
my fate is to love her from afar
[Music]
we must let her decide our fate she must
have the choice
[Music]
thank you so much for being here
congratulations on a beautiful movie um
whenever i have people as accomplished
as any of you i actually like to go back
to the beginning and ask what was your
first job in this business the first
time you felt you could call yourself an
actor or call yourself a writer and
let's start with erica because i you do
many things
i
i was an intern in a costume shop no way
yeah for anything fun or like
fun oh you mean the show yeah yeah um
summerstock
that's so cool oh my gosh you must have
worked with so many talented people
um yes yes
haley for you
uh
first stop sorry we are all very jet
lagged so this is why
we're dragging
um
i guess
the first job
i can say i felt like i was an actor
was called music and lyrics
[Music]
even though i begged them not to give me
the job
in my audition
because i ended up just bursting out in
tears
um in front of
hugh grant and drew barrymore because i
was so starstruck
and uh and i was like you know i had to
learn a dance the day before i went to
the audition in new york
and i went to this um
choreographer's house that i'd never met
before um
and he taught me uh this dance where i
had to like
grind on the floor so i was attempting
to do this
um in front of hugh and drew and um
that's when the tears started coming and
i was like i'm so sorry i i
can't i
i should just go back to ohio
and uh and i was actually on my way back
when i got a call from eileen starger i
think her name is the casting director
and she said can you just come and try
to learn to dance with the choreographer
for a few hours
and then i was eventually cast and moved
to new york and
[Music]
yes do you think the crying helped or
possibly must have because the dancing
was not very good
peter what about for you what's the
first time you felt you could call
yourself an actor
well i can tell you about my the last
regular job i had that convinced me i
couldn't do that anymore
needed to be an actor desperately or
anything but that regular normal job
but that's a very boring story
um uh yeah first film
living in oblivion um which was sort of
lucky
uh thanks uh lucky one to have coming
out of the gates like haley uh working
with some really cool people and uh
just didn't realize um
i remember not realizing
cut meant cut
i didn't you know know anything movie
actors did all this stuff and they
yelled cut and perhaps they thought i
was method because i was still
doing the scene
off camera and i thought it was more
like theater or something i was very
confused about the whole rules and
everything but
um i learned pretty quickly yeah cut i
didn't
why why is everybody walking away i
don't i didn't i didn't really
understand it
um anyway
you know usually people start off with
like a mcdonald's commercial and you
both your very first
jobs it sounds right it sounds a little
bit indie and pompous but no
i do remember going to a um
a toothpaste commercial
before i
got music and lyrics and i have really
crooked bad teeth
um and everyone there it was this was in
hollywood and everyone there had really
perfect and shiny teeth and i was like
oh this is what you have to this is what
your teeth have to look like to be an
actor
but i proved them wrong
joe what about for you what do you sort
of consider your first job in this
business
um
well i started at busking
are you serious yeah i started out
busking in covent garden in london
i was a magician
at the age of 11
and
i called myself the great kazam
and
and i wore a tail coat
and like the green corduroy flares that
i wore normally but a tail coat
and um
and uh and did illusions
and i asked my mum if i could keep doves
in the house
um
because a magician needs doves and uh
and she said no and i was indignant
um you know for
stopping my creativity
uh but anyway i i cut out some pieces of
white satin fabric
and sewed them together and then stuffed
them with terrelline and put a little
fake beak on the nose and then i
velcroed the doves to my shoulder
and had a little string that went down
my arm like that and so
i used to pull the string and the duff
would go like that and give away the
trick
and also i had a pigeon made of gray
cotton who used to die and i used to
make quite a lot of money as well like
30 pounds a day
why did you give it up i mean i'm glad
things worked out the way they did but
because i don't think he has kids
no no no i did
this guy called ken livingston who later
became the mayor of london but he took
over something called the glc which is
the greater london council
and he decreed that no one under 16 was
allowed to bust
which i was desperate it took away my
audience and um
and i tried kids parties and stuff but i
felt like the audience didn't quite get
me
um
so that was when i started i picked up a
super 8 camera and started making short
films that's amazing can you still do
any kind of sleight of hand a little bit
yeah yeah i'm not expecting you to pull
a double and here we are all of us
weirdos
like i wish we would have known each
other
that would all
been interesting
well here you are with a beautiful
adaptation of sereno and i actually want
to start with erica
would you rather i not okay
[Laughter]
no but you uh originally adapted this
from obviously the edmond rosten play um
what was it about this particular work
it's my favorite play of all time but i
would love to know what interested you
in it and may did you want to do it you
know without per se the nose
um and also as a musical
um well i love the play
uh very much and i
um
you know was sort of curious about it
and had some questions and
one was about
the main character and the nose in the
in the rastan play the character of
cyrano spends a lot of time talking
about his
um really large nose and um
feeling that that is what makes him
unlovable and i was i just wondered what
what it would be like if if
if he didn't if that if we didn't we
just never knew what it was that he felt
made him physically unattractive and
then i was also really interested in the
character of roxanne and um
i wondered uh what it would be like if
she had a little more agency there's an
amazing amazing french production of
this play where in the balcony scene the
characters of christian and cyrano are
talking to roxanne on the balcony and
they just wheel the balcony out from
under her and she like floats in this
you know sky and it's so beautiful but
to me it was kind of the
whole problem with the piece which is
that she doesn't even have legs to stand
on you know when she finds out she's
been duped for 15 years she doesn't get
angry she doesn't say why she doesn't
kind of demand that she get be given her
life back and so i was curious what
would happen if she did
and these were just you know questions i
had kind of
alone at my desk
you know thinking about it as a theater
piece and then i really wanted it to be
through composed and sort of cinematic
um ironically and uh
so i approached the man the national and
asked if they would write the music and
um songs and originally we thought it
would just be there's five acts in the
wrist and play we thought it would just
be one song per act um and we just
started working on it and then we did a
workshop with uh peter and haley and joe
saw it and then
he wanted to make a film of it wow
joe what interested you and specifically
in this adaptation of sierra no and
doing a musical
um
i'd always wanted to do a musical since
i saw uh
well maybe cabaret but um but in
particular uh lars von trier's dancer in
the dark i kind of was really interested
in the idea of a
musical that wasn't like
musicals um
so
i'd been drawn to that idea and then i
and then haley invited me to see the
workshop they did up in chester
connecticut
and um
and i was just really struck by
peter and and haley's
um
the relationship between the two
and and how emotional the play
was um
and i think that the casting of peter in
that in that role just had a kind of um
immediacy and an authenticity in a
um
that you know that
you as as erica talks about as well you
you know with other
cyranos you you feel like with the nose
you feel like the actor can kind of you
know at the end of the night take off
his nose and go to the bar and
you know chat up roxanne and
whatever and um
and uh and i just found the whole thing
incredibly emotional yeah
and peter cyrano is one of the greatest
characters ever created i feel for stage
or screen had he been a dream role for
you or did you you never even considered
maybe you know playing this character
no i never considered it um
probably person on a personal level and
this is just me obviously sort of
speaking to what joe just mentioned
yeah it always was a really handsome
actor and a fake news and
i sort of
didn't know my way into it and you know
i know it's a beautifully written piece
um but until erica had stripped it down
to its bare essentials
kept the heart
but got rid of the nose
oh i see what it did there
that was unintended but thank you
the kneecaps remained
but the heart no
it just it just suddenly
spoke to me
um
but she didn't write it
my size is not a substitute at least in
the original production and with the
film we had to sort of embrace the
reality of the time that cyrano lives in
this my size is not a substitute for the
nose
um
it i think's getting rid of the the nose
makes it
reach to all of us because there is a
theatricality to the nose
it's it's and i think it was probably
really fun and irreverent when rastan
wrote this 120 years ago to have a actor
on stage with this fake nose and
you could you know it was something
probably really interesting and exciting
and
new but we this is this is the time
we're living in now and what gets right
to our heart perhaps isn't a handsome
actor and a fake nose and
and uh
um
so yeah so it just suddenly spoke to me
um um in that way
and then obviously uh the music
having these sort of no no offense but
uh long-winded
uh monologues about love
that you know people used to go to the
theater and they get out of the cold and
they're there for five hours they don't
care how long it is but
we have cell phones now and places to go
and people to see and
art for some reason it shouldn't be but
our time is more limited but the 24
hours are still in a day
but we
have less patience for that
so what eric did about asking the
national to do these love songs and
replace of these monologues it just
makes it
just it moves the piece much more
quickly forward and just you know it's
music as our heartbeat and it's more
forgiving
you can listen to a love song all day
but hearing your friend talk about love
not so much maybe
you know
um
so anyway that that really having very
little patience myself that really
really spoke and having less lines to
learn
uh it really spoke to me
um forgive me for not knowing because i
i know haley has been a professional
singer has a beautiful voice for you and
i haven't been okay
but you do you sound beautiful in this
did you have to train or is this let's
not put a spotlight on the differences
between my voices sorry
no i mean like everyone i know who has
seen this movie is like i didn't know
peter dinklage could sing like that did
you have to train specifically for this
movie or have you always had that talent
you're looking at me like you're not a
good singer you're a good thing who are
you talking to haley oh obviously you're
talking to me
[Laughter]
sorry
uh um
well i was the pirate king and pirates
of penzance in high
school um no i mean you know sorry to
take over this q a um um
uh but i am no um
what i learned about
you just gotta overcome your fears and
then dive off the cliff and acting uh
there's a lot of that that you need to
do
when you're an actor um um and this was
something i had never sung in a movie
before not many actors have all right
given the opportunity i'll jump at the
opportunity um but the key was not to
pretend to be a singer you weren't
um just to sing from whatever soul you
have
um and sing as yourself
because matt berninger who's the singer
and lyricist for the national has
probably one of my favorite voices if
not my favorite voice
in in music today
i'll never sound like him
we have the same similar baritone
register but i'll never sound like him
and i had to stop listening to him to
stop doing an imitation
of him
because we all sound like aretha
franklin in the shower right
or stevie wonder or freddie mercury but
we're not
um
and until you come to terms with that
uh um that's what sets you free
uh matt sings the closing song doesn't
he oh yeah he does he hasn't yeah it's
definitely not me
[Laughter]
haley for you i this might be my
favorite portrayal ever of roxanne
because i have seen
so many versions where um i don't relate
to her as much and i find her to be
incredibly compelling and sympathetic um
what interested you you know was it
specifically that you wanted to play
roxanne was it this script what really
drew you to this part
um
well i was living in new york and i
really wanted to get involved in theater
because i had never done it
before and
and then i asked my agent would you
please think of me
if there's an opportunity to
you know bring someone their coffee
and then very shortly after that i
received a call uh
from my agent saying oh hey yeah there's
a there's a
new play
a new musical that's being developed by
erica schmidt and peter dinklage is
playing cyrano and they'd love
for you to come just read
for a week
with the national
i was like wow this is an incredible
opportunity
you know i had no idea what to expect um
and in that week um
i
just had the most incredible time with
erica and pete and aaron and it just
felt like um we had all bonded in a
really special way and
um they accepted me for my fencing
costumes that i wore frequently
and uh and
uh
you know it was just this really lovely
way to
um take risks and and
um
yeah just a very beautiful rehearsal
environment
and uh
love to these guys and then
um
i fell in love with the character then
um
and
and then eric asked me to do
the um
the play
in connecticut
similar to um how much i love roxanna in
this movie i think that this is my
favorite portrayal of christian i've
ever seen because frankly he's usually
kind of portrayed as just a dullard um
and i really found him compelling in
this i'm curious was that like a
conscious effort you made to like not
just give roxanne agency but christian
as well
um well i love i love christian um i
feel like he's the only one with a moral
conscience in the piece and
he's um
you know he doesn't prioritize
uh letters and books and poetry the way
that these two characters do
but he's um
you know he's a soldier and he's caught
up in this um
you know triangle and
he he's
he sacrifices himself in the end because
he can't bear to think of um roxanne
being unhappy and he can't bear to
go on with the betrayal and i find that
so noble um when we did the play uh you
know i had i i thought
i really thought that
um
i'd
sit so stupid but i thought that i i was
inventing something that christian was
going to kill himself i thought you know
i think i really found something in the
text i've looked at all the extant
versions and i think i think he i think
he should kill himself and then i saw
the famous french production and he um
stood
um with his arms out like christ and red
roses fell from his chest as he fell
back and i thought oh yeah that's okay
that's
that's true it's just true that's what
he does um
but but i think kelvin is so
beautiful in the in the role um
i don't know if you want to talk joe we
had kelvin here a few weeks ago and he
talked about like kind of being
surprised that you reached out to him um
what made you think i mean i've seen him
sing in the high note um and i know he's
a fantastic actor but what made you
think of him for this role
um
i'd seen waves
and uh
i thought he was extraordinary in that
and
i was looking for someone who could
convey
a sense of openness and trust and
innocence and
when um
you know he
when when cyrano
tells him something he believes him
immediately he doesn't try and look for
ulterior motives or second guess anyone
and kelvin's kind of like that really
yeah
he seemed like
the guy with the heart
so much of this film obviously hinges on
chemistry and i don't just mean between
cyrano and roxanne it's uh you know
roxanne and christian and christian and
cyrano who actually have this beautiful
relationship uh the two of you got to
work together obviously in the stage
production um was that chemistry pretty
instantaneous or do you find that you
know that's chemistry's chemistry and
film between actors is a myth really
yeah now you have me doesn't exist yeah
okay um
uh
it's based on respect what are you
saying here it's based on respect if you
have two actors who admire each other's
talent and ability and skill
then they'll have a chemistry because
they'll match each other and then keep
climbing
if you have an actor who
doesn't really think the other actor is
much good
then they won't have any chemistry at
all it just comes from a kind of respect
of the craft
more than anything you ever had to work
with actors that didn't have that
chemistry yeah what do you do um
try and cut around it
[Laughter]
well alien people don't say which film
[Laughter]
i'm going through the rolodex um
haley and peter i mean did you find that
you know you you sort of fell into this
relationship pretty naturally um i'm
assuming having respect for each other
well uh
we had the benefit of the stage
production which sort of
the rehearsal process
um which you're not often granted with
films because
uh they're perhaps unnecessary or
indulgent or you have actors who think
they're useless because it's a film
um and it kills spontaneity in the
moment but with this which you know
there's there's a monochrome of truth to
that but i also i also love rehearsals
because they
uh develop that familiarity and i think
that's why a lot of directors have them
in the first place
um but with the play and then also with
this we had to do a lot of rehearsals
uh uh um in terms of you know everything
so it really helps because it's it's
just it's just it's work and it's not um
you it just you get right into it and
you find you develop a rhythm together
yeah um you don't like suddenly try to
match each other's rhythm or or any of
that
in the movie you just develop it it
becomes you just sort of raise each
other up as you go along in the
rehearsal process and then we got to do
it again for the film which is really
nice um it's just yeah it's great
haley's an amazing listener she's right
there with you
and as joe said it's all about that it's
respecting who you're working with and
listening to them and them making you a
better actor as well it's just it's just
and kelvin and i had that and ben and i
have that it's just it's all about that
you're only as good as the actor you're
working with truly
i mean and also because this is such an
open-hearted um
film
just that that getting to know someone
and and
being able to allow yourself to be seen
and you know not feel shy or you know if
i'm
breathing snot down pete's mouth you
know i'm not gonna you know
you know it's gonna be you know oh sorry
there's some snot and
uh and it's gonna be okay you know and
he's he has such a sense a good sense of
humor about everything um which makes
him really really easy to work with
um
yeah
um i'm curious you can do as actors all
this preparation you can learn your
lines what is it like to actually step
on the set with this stunning production
design and put on those costumes how
much does that actually help you finally
lock into that character
and did you keep any of your costumes
because i would have kept them all did
you really good on you
it was really an incredible experience
working with jacqueline duran
and massimo
uh because
um
[Music]
they were so incredibly collaborative
and you know if i thought oh i think
roxanne should have a bird in her hair
and then we could have long discussions
about why roxanne should have a bird in
her hair and even with sarah greenwood
you know i would have dreams about foxes
and then the next day i would come to
set and there would be foxes painted on
the walls and so all of a sudden i felt
like i was living you know i could i was
living in my imagination and whatever
the madness manifestation of that
um became real and ended up in the
costumes and on the set
um so that was a really uh that was the
first time i've ever experienced
anything like that where everyone is
speaking the same cinematic language and
um and then
yeah and then that ends up
in the film
peter for you i don't think you can wear
a soldier's uniform and not have it not
change your attitude to some degree
um
you're right
and carrying a sword well rare am i
called upon to play a soldier
um but when it's
a musical
everybody can be a soldier
truly though that's what i mean it's
kind of what joe
sets up so beautifully in erica's story
it is
it is a movie and and
you bend the rules and um
uh that's what i kind of love if the
52-year-old guy my size who's
respected in the military you don't see
that
really much um and that's what i loved
about it and the costumes and all of
that it's it's it had this beautiful
sense like haley was saying of just
transporting you there and into the into
what we do for a living which is pretend
and
um it's very heightened when you're
in a military costume singing songs on a
volcano
that's right you shot us this is funny i
was just going to ask for each of you
what ended up being the most challenging
scene or moment you know something erica
that you did in the adaptation that
maybe you struggled with the most but
then i heard you shot on an active
volcano and i sort of feel like i just
told you that one second 30 seconds ago
see i'm listening um
and i sort of feel like
that blows everything away um and did it
go off at one point
yeah on the last date
yeah that we we were um
yeah i kind of wanted a strong contrast
to the notto the town of notto where we
where we shot most of the movie um which
was this kind of honey-colored
stone
and sort of baroque
lusciousness
um and so
and so there was mount etna so that was
obviously the place where we should
shoot the battle
and it was this black you know sand um
and rock
um and that was exciting and so we built
a set at 16 000 feet um
where the air was very very thin um
right up by the summit
um and we're told that it wasn't going
to slow till february so that was all
right we were there in december
and then about four or five days before
we started shooting the snow came down
and buried the set um and the camera
platform and the 100-foot techno crane
and so that was inaccessible uh so we
had to move we had to we had to find a
new
place to shoot which then was about
eight eight thousand feet
um and we shot with um a tripod only um
because we'd buried the crane and um
and uh and it was that was probably the
most challenging experience of my career
and then on the last day the the volcano
erupted and um
and we picked up our camera cases and
ran
off we're laughing because you're okay
but at the time was it terrifying
yeah it was a bit it was worrying yeah
it was worrying
as pete says it's not the actual lava
you worry about is the projectile rocks
that the volcano flies out and
do you have footage of any of this
because you could make a hole no we were
running we weren't filming
[Laughter]
okay aside from the very sicilian
approach to that volcano
yeah yeah she's
no she's all right she's all right
it's the earthquakes you got to worry
about
aside from the exploding volcano for
each of you what ended up being you know
the scene that you probably spent the
most time with let's start with erica
i know you you you were trying to avoid
eye contact so i wouldn't call on you
but i was
um well
the play version was i had taken the
wrong stand play and made it really
small like cut
from 30 actors down to just 10
and really focused on the christian
sereno roxanne relationship
and um you know joe
really wanted uh
to return to rastan to the first act
being really big which is the theater
act
um
and
you know meeting all of the echelon of
society and um you know pageantry and
baroque the stage play was kind of
modern dress so
um
that that was a big challenge um trying
to figure out how to
uh
keep
what
joe had liked from what i had done but
then also
honor stand and then also kind of grow
it back up
again there are two huge set pieces in
the stand play the ballad that he
composes while he's dueling valver and
then also the nose speech which is very
famous and hugely long and i had cut
entirely so that was like a big
struggle and juggling act
haley for you
um
i think
um
probably the balcony scene
uh because
you know there's
the
worry
i mean and obviously past roxannes have
been
massively you know deceived and you know
he's speaking for christian and
his voice sounds different and
you know me and
you know i go like well obviously she
would know
that it was him that was
speaking for you know she knows if she
knows
cyrano so well then why doesn't she know
that that's his voice
you know that that was always kind of a
tricky thing for me and so i guess it's
something that i was interested in
um
when developing the character and and
thinking about the relationship between
uh cyrano and roxanne like how much
did roxanne
know or not know and how can we
veer from you know
everything we know about roxanne and
about her being kind of
duped or fooled can't what if she you
know what if she did know that it was
him and
what does that say about her and her
resistance
to allowing herself to you know believe
this
this lie
um
and so yeah just kind of
uh kind of walking that tightrope
was wasn't really diffi it wasn't
difficult but it was it made things more
interesting for me as an actor to
um
to contemplate and then uh
yeah make choices i guess
it's probably my favorite scene so
i'm just saying it worked um
peter for you
um
yeah i'm not sure difficult but just
sort of
um
uh
made me
still try and figure i'm still trying to
figure it out uh the the final scene
um
sereno knows he's going to die
he doesn't know at what moment but
um he has a
strong sense that he is going to maybe
die
in front of roxanne
um
and he still can't
tell her
i mean he's basically it's it's very
it's it's very um
he's you know it's it's
his skin is as thin as it's gonna get
um
he's as vulnerable as he's ever going to
be
he's basically telling her
he's doing he's telling everything but
he's still denying that he's telling her
so just how to how to get your head
around that as a as a person who
uh is an actor who doesn't really have a
problem speaking his mind
um and perhaps has told
uh uh people that he loves them and
they've run away
i have the opposite problem that cyrano
has
um
i don't
[Laughter]
because i'm an actor inherently you have
you have the opposite problem yeah um so
just that sort of challenge of that of a
guy that
who did you say you loved
it
um
just getting right to that edge and
still
even when just not jumping off really
it's just it's just it's beautifully
written yeah it's beautifully
framed and i just
had to uh
figure out my my my challenge within it
uh i'm not i think we have time for a
couple quick questions from the audience
um if you have one just raise your hand
try to get to
i can't be right down there i'm sorry
i have no idea what that was but i'll
take the
an blame specific place for you haley
please describe your experience singing
at such high notes
hitting the high notes in a tight dress
this
[Laughter]
i assume that was for haley um
well it was much easier than projecting
those high notes eight months pregnant
on stage uh in connecticut with these
guys
yes um so yeah not much room for the
diaphragm with the
eight pound baby inside of you
um actually there are
different corsets there's just you know
practical answers for
um you know how to especially with i
need more there was a different course
that so you know is expandable
yeah wow they make them expandable yeah
there's just you know
some elastic
to accommodate
that doesn't defeat the purpose of a
corset
well we weren't going for looks i guess
[Laughter]
i think we have time for one more if
there's one sure way over there
i've always loved this story because it
is sort of a self-standing masterpiece
it's famously you know not to the allied
with different roser movements in french
literature
it seems to me that people often take or
feel free to take a lot of creative
liberties with this story
would you agree with that and how do you
think your choices
will
impact
people's perception of this
it's very welcome
this more for erica or eric and joe i
guess
yeah
um
well yes i mean i guess like this the
steve martin the ruxin movie roxanne or
even you could say you've got mail
um you know there are lots of
retellings of this story um i
i was trying to really
honor the original um
but
um kind of
make it
make it modern and
and and really make it sing
i
listened to the dozener's music when i
was adapting it and i tried to make it
very very very spare so that it was just
kind of the essential
pieces like um you know if it was a 14
line
poem about love i tried to say look at
what is the like absolute pure heart of
what is being said and then with matt
berninger who wrote the lyrics
allow the songs to become the kind of
more
exquisite elevated poetry of the piece
and i guess in terms of what um i hope
people would take away in in terms of
the value of the original versus this i
i feel like if more people become
interested in the play and and find
rastan and read it and seek it out i
think that would be an amazing thing and
i feel like if it um
if it allows more people to relate to
the character to there's a the nose to
me is like a conspiracy between actor
and audience it allows you to laugh at
the thing that he says he finds painful
because ultimately you know that it's
not paining the person at all and
originally my idea was to remove that
and not have him talk about it but never
as peter said to have his height be a
stand-in for it but to you know just
have it be unsaid and and in that way i
i hope that we can all find our own
um
thing our own nose the thing that we
feel is unlovable about us that we'd
like to hide or we think that nobody
will be able to see past and i hope that
that's
that that that's what people take from
it or see in it ultimately joe what
about for you
why does everybody look upset when i
call on them
or not upset but like struck jet lag
[ __ ] leg
um sorry i think eric has said it all i
think eric has answered that question
i mean no i mean you know you have done
such an amazing job of taking classic
stories and
basically doing the best versions of
them um was it intimidating to take on
something like cyrano knowing how
beloved it was and you know getting to
put your own twist on it
um
no i was a bit intimidated by the by the
balcony scene yeah uh because uh i had
to get it right
uh because they're
because it's such an iconic scene
um
but no i'm i'm you know i'm i'm uh
i'm lucky that i'm dyslexic and uh and
and didn't you know i don't have this
kind of
um
i don't know i i came to reading quite
late
um
and
uh and i get to
educate myself through the process of
making films
and that's all i'm doing really i'm i'm
just learning stuff and
i don't you know i don't have anything
to
um
i make films about not about what i know
but about what i want to know um
and that's an exciting process for me
um there is many different versions of a
book as there are readers and all i'm
doing is
making
an adaptation of the or i'm not even an
adaptation i'm making the film
that happened in my head as i read or
you know
i read that book
um
and uh and and people will respond to it
you know i try and leave enough space
uh for people to project their own
feelings and and and take from it what
they
need to take from it what you know um
it's the
it's the it's the
it's in between
the frames that's interesting you know
we we create
actually i don't know if we do any more
but with
with projected film we create the moving
image you know um
uh with the persistence of vision and um
and so i believe in that i don't i don't
feel a way of resp responsibility
because it's just one iteration you know
there'll be other
versions of cyrano just as there will be
other
versions of pride and prejudice um
but they won't be better well you know
pride and prejudice and zombies was
pretty good um no it's not
[Laughter]
i worked on it i can say that you did i
did what did you do we'll talk backstage
yeah um
uh so yeah i don't feel i don't feel
like this massive weight of
responsibility really i'm i'm
uh it's just about learning yeah you
know
well i want to remind everyone uh this
movie will actually be opening december
17th for a week in los angeles um please
spread the word it is such a special
film before it opens wide and also the
soundtrack is now available um so please
go out and purchase that it's such great
music thank you all for being here thank
you all for being such a great guest
thank you
[Music]
you